[Musique]
en vous faisant rencontrer ce soir des
jeunes aveugles notre but n'est pas de
vous proposer une étude sur la cécité
mais de vous faire découvrir les vrais
problèmes les joies et les soucis
quotidiens de ces jeunes qui à 20 ans
veulent croire en la vie qui s'ouvre de
vente
[Musique]
réussir son insertion dans la vie
professionnelle du pays et prendre ainsi
sa place au même titre qu'un autre au
sein de la société et pour tous le but
essentiel
cela représente un courage un effort de
volonté considérable on compte en france
43 milles aveugle dont 15000 en âge de
travailler
les métiers traditionnels de la
brosserie de la vannerie de lacheisserie
fortement concurrencée par la
fabrication industrielle ne sont plus
réservées qu'aux jeunes aveugles qui
n'ont pas réussi à poursuivre leurs
études ou qui sont trop peu doué pour
être reclassé dans une autre forme
d'activité
quant aux métiers de l'industrie
métallurgique il constitue depuis
quelques années a débouché nouveau à
paris dans le quartier de belleville le
centre de formation professionnelle pour
travailleurs handicapés à sur
l'apprentissage de cette future ouvriers
ni plus ni moins intelligents que les
voyants il supplée la défaillance de la
vue par un meilleur usage de leurs
facultés
le rôle des sensations tactiles est ici
de première importance avec les mains il
découvre apprennent et retiennent les
machines et plus dangereuse
il est évidemment de leur faire
connaître contre les franges de la
machine pas falloir touchés voilà
les machines c'est sympa d sans quoi des
idées qu'on a pris contact avec je crois
qu'on peut très bien s'habituer
il suffit d'avoir bien connaissance avec
la chimie ensuite peut très bien y
arriver
j'avais terminé mes études et ensuite
comme je n'avais aucun métier non
classés à l'atelier de vannerie
j'ai demandé pour faire un autre métier
parce que le métier de la vannerie ne
vous plaisait pas ce n'est pas que cela
me plaisait pas c'est surtout parce que
je ne vais pas de moyens après dans mon
département pour pouvoir continuer alors
quelles sont les possibilités qui leur
sont offertes dans l'industrie quel
métier parce qu'il exerçait dans
l'industrie métallurgique
ils ont le poste pour débuter deux os un
polyvalent du pont ils peuvent nous
travaillons sur plusieurs machines ici
et qu'on fait à dire plusieurs postes de
travail dans une usine
ils peuvent pas tenir tous les postes
sauf celui d'ajusteur oui sauf celui
d'ajusteur et puis en ressort aussi les
travaux qui ne demandent pas de contrôle
visuel très important quant au métier de
tactilo grâce les aveugles apprennent
grâce à une machine de sténo qui
impriment en braille abrégé sur un
rouleau de papier permettant ainsi de
relire le texte avec les doigts puis de
le dactylographiée sur une machine à
écrire ordinaire le stage dure fronde
yann moix ici monsieur ni eu moins 18
mois mais on se doit de pratiquer 11
mois de pratique et vous avez on a au
départ c'est un mois de 5 mois et demi
de
on apprend le dry pour les personnes qui
ne connaissaient pas devra les personnes
dans mon cas qui ne connaissaient pas le
braille il ya combien de temps que vous
avez perdu la vue et deux ans il y aura
2 ans le bij et comment ça s'est passé
c'est un accident de voiture c'est grâce
à leur acuité tactile que les élèves
masseurs kinésithérapeutes de l'institut
valentin 8 à paris pas de suivre les
mêmes études que les voyants et obtenir
les mêmes diplômes que tout au long de
leur scolarité les jeunes s'aveuglent
pratiquer une gymnastique particulière
qui développent leur propre équilibre
permet une représentation approfondie
des corps dans l'espace et les autorise
ainsi à pratiquer comme les autres
kinésithérapeutes des séances de
gymnastique correctives
quant aux massages ils n'ont plus de
secrets pour eux sur les gouttières
vertébrale le monde et non de recevoir
il est au moins au départ de l'année
cette exploration vous a permis de vous
rendre compte d'une part de la
température lopez il y à une élévation
des température locale
il faut penser à une congestion d'autre
part vous vous sentez une tribulation
musculaire il faudra penser que votre
massage à d'aspirine ovation par contre
si dans une manipulation d'articulation
d'un bras par exemple vous hanter eux
que le patient se croyant vous lui fait
mal et encore là je pense que vous
pouvez peut-être aussi bien et en voyant
et peut-être voir
la série à bio car il est plus facile de
se faire un masque facial peu de
réprimer une contracture du mollet rio
vie du malade
nous sommes une nous comprenons
peut-être mieux ces difficultés et pour
lui même nous sommes une sorte de nous
avons dépassé beaucoup d'obstacles et
peut-être que sur le plan moral un grand
malade se sent plus à l'aise avec nous
après avoir vu l'apprentissage de
métiers que peuvent exercer les aveugles
c'est à son travail que nous avons
rencontré lucienne et les standardistes
elle a 20 ans ses aptitudes ségou la
porter vers les carrières musicales
mais son désir d'indépendance et sa
volonté farouche de saint céré ou plutôt
dans le monde des voyants lui ont fait
choisir un tout autre métier
vous écrivez en bras une brigitte et en
braille quoi et alors que j'écris tous
les numéros que les jeunes et de
l'intérieur mono monde lors par exemple
au début de la matinée et le poste 128
qui me demandait philippe auguste lancer
des centres et john fichiers à côté je
cherche deux numéros qui correspond à
philippe auguste et là je passe pour
cette année mais ce fichier c'est un
fichier en braille affiché en moins
c'est moi qui lui ai dit si tu es le
fichier alors par exemple j'ai une de
mes collègues qui m'a dit et tous les
numéros des centres fpf province alors
c'était moi qui ai fait le fichier vous
vous dites que vous voyez un petit peu
c'est à dire que vous distinguer un peu
les ombres et les lumières mais vous
avez tout de même fait toutes mes études
j'ai fait toutes mes études spécialisées
cette école spécialisée
c'est l'institut national des jeunes
aveugles boulevard des invalides à paris
il est ouvert aux garçons et aux filles
et fonctionne sous le régime de
l'internât les élèves sont entièrement
prise en charge par l'état
parallèlement une formation musicale
approfondie il suffit dissidents études
secondaires pour lesquelles
l'utilisation d'un matériel adapté est
souvent nécessaire
alors avez vous trouvé vous pourriez
m'ont dit t'es où se trouve le même
alors la mer d'azov vous me trouvez en
partant de la lettre aux accents graves
vous avez ici dans la mer noire si vous
montez vers le nord
vous trouvez un petit passage entre deux
presqu'île l'après style de l'ouest
termine la péninsule de crimée c'est la
presqu'île de kersch en passe vous avez
celle qui termine à l'est le caucase et
si la presqu'île de taman d'un petit
passage et le détroit de kertch qui vous
conduit dans la merde alors mais qu'avez
vous appris alors à cet institut de la
désinstaller
alors j'ai fait
bien entendu j'ai continué politique
générale et j'ai fait surtout beaucoup
de lui dit que vu que tu t'es comme une
matière qui préserve donc j'ai beaucoup
travaillé les instruments et leurs là je
trouvais toute la journée et tous les
soirs je vous retourne faire du piano
tous les soins le second travaille tous
les soirs je retourne à du rock
j'aurai le temps des décisions est
monsieur philippe hesnault jusqu'à 8
heures vous avez une jolie robe très
élégante comme enfin au point de vue
mode vous voulez suivre là bas aux
astres et passion alors comment faites
vous expliquez moi comment je fais
n'importe quoi on en entend parler dans
la radio alors déjà ça nous donne une
petite idée
quand on va dans les magasins 27
personnes nous empêche de touché alors
comme une autre chose se rend compte
c'est une forme qui nous plaît pas là
comme une personnalité
les couleurs par exemple alors aux
belles couleurs je les vois un petit peu
quand même
enfin vous êtes sûr de les voir non pas
tout le temps c'est à dire qu'il ya des
choses je me fais une petite idée quoi
se disent oh expliqué moir c'est à dire
que par exemple on me dit que telle robe
par exemple est à fleurs et des fleurs
des bleus des rouges et moi je m'imagine
ou moi ce que ça peut être une fleur par
exemple et j'essaye de l'imaginer
couleurs qu'est ce que c'est une fleur
au point d'écrire une fleur je n'imagine
d'abonnés du toucher il faut que j'aie
touche par exemple vraiment imaginer ce
que c'est
c'est ainsi qu'en récréation les élèves
aveugles découvre les fleurs
et vos loisirs alors qu elle sentit
maintenant
vous aimez l'asie je vous disais avant
jeu j'ai fait de beaucoup de natation
quand j'étais à l'école on avait tous
régulièrement toutes les semaines la
piscine me faisais de la gymnastique
sommes toujours mal au stade et pas
autrement aujourd'hui on fait beaucoup
de promenades vous allez au musée
oui vous également et je crois qu'il y
avait une exposition vous avez envie de
voir par dessus tout oui je voulais les
voir tout aux camions alors j'ai choisi
je suis élève et qu'une de mes collègues
d'ailleurs parce que la dame qui
travaille à côté de vos oui alors je
suis avec elle c'est une chose très
difficile il faut voir alors il fallait
que je vous connais qui me tue voix
complètement et qu'ils sachent quand il
expliqué nous sommes partis toutes les
deux jours de l'ascension d'un camion et
elle a bien suivi et c'était formidable
outil formidable pour me dames c'est la
lumière la grande lumière qui l'attirait
mais elle a bien distinguer beaucoup de
choses même ce fameux collier de
toutankhamon où il ya toutes ces perles
qui qui descendent vous savez elle s'est
approchée vraiment vous savez que vous
volonté de dire je l'aurais vu c'était
ça c'est ça qui prime et 6ème vous
estimez avoir réussi votre intégration
dans le monde des ouailles en annonçant
non on a toujours vous savez je
découvrais toujours quelque chose
n'importe comment mais enfin je crois
déjà été débloquée assez bon parce que
je pensais pas montré aussi bien je suis
parti dans l'idée que tout le monde
devait me considérer comme tout le monde
voyez que je suis rentré avec mes
collègues on parlait comme ça et la
première chose que je dis je vous savez
je ne vois pas d'accord mais enfin je
suis comme tout le monde il faut le
considérer comme tout le monde parle si
je fais quelque chose qui ne va pas mais
elles ont le droit de me dira pas tout à
fait et s'est très bien adapté ses 1,6 l
a compris tout de suite que le maniement
du standard enfin la pétéca vue
probablement à son étoile mais enfin
elle s'est très bien adapté alors je
crois qu'avec la volonté c'est ce que
c'est ça le volant placé la base des
taux et une personne ne voyant pas est
obligé d'avoir beaucoup plus de volonté
parce que si dès le début elle compte
sur les autres c'est fini après la pluie
de coups le courage et volonté de bien
faire
[Musique]
oh
de la volonté il en a fallu aussi à jean
pierre leguay pour obtenir après quinze
années d'études musicales un premier
prix d'orgue au conservatoire national
supérieur de paris
on dit que les jeunes aveugles ont
beaucoup de facilités pour apprendre la
musique qu'en pensez vous les gens
pensent qu'il convient tout d'abord
avant d'aller plus avant de lever une
équivoque à savoir que les aveugles ne
sont pas plus musicien que n'importe
quelle autre personne
alors les difficultés ont été surtout du
point de vue mémoire mois pour une
raison très simple
d'une part parce que la cause de la cité
et d'autre part du fait que je lis mes
partitions qui existent en braille que
je les lis avec l'humain avec les deux
mains et les doigts jouer et que je
jouais de toute façon avec avec les deux
pays qui m'a bien sûr je ne peux donc
pas faire les choses à la fois et il est
donc absolument interdit de déchiffrer
ce qui m'oblige à reprendre entièrement
par coeur la moindre petite chose
moindre petite pièce doit être apprises
par coeur et bien l'organiser à notre
âne les champs en 1967 gagne de l'ordre
de 80 mille francs par mois cela oui et
je crois que depuis que vous travaillez
vous vous êtes mariés
en effet je suis marié j'ai deux enfants
garçons et filles
justement est-ce que vous vous sentez
complètement intégrée à la vie des
voyants au monde des voyants bien sûr
sinon longtemps par intégration à
parvenir à faire tout comme les voyants
amène une dune va mener une vie
exactement calquée sur celle d'avant
je vous dirais que c'est assez difficile
prenez par exemple exemple des loisirs
enfin il ya un certain nombre de choses
qu'un aveugle ne peut pas faire autant
qu'un voyant dix ans avec par exemple ne
peut pas non plus conduire sa voiture
enfin quantité de choses que les voyants
peuvent faire et pas nous bon mais ce
sont peut-être des choses des choses
assez mineures mais l'essentiel
l'essentiel de la vie peut être mené
d'être vécue par un aveugle devance
aussi bien que par quelqu'un de
clairvoyant que pensez vous des jeunes
aveugles que l'on rencontre parfois dans
le métro vendant des billets le tri ou
mendiants gens pensent que c'est fort
triste c'est une chose qui m'attriste
profondément
bien sûr il ne sert à rien de leur jeter
leur jeter la pierre
encore faudrait-il savoir ce qui les a
amenés à cet état de choses
pourquoi sont-ils là mais il est bien il
est bien certain que c'est très c'est
probablement humiliant pour eux et on
est même très humiliant pour nous car
nous savons très bien que cette image
des aveugles dans le métro mais
finalement celle qui est peut-être la
plus connue car c'est celle qui ai vus
quotidiennement par le maximum de
personnes
et finalement les aveugles sont ceux qui
dans une grande partie en tout cas les
aveugles sont ceux qui mendient dans le
métro sont ceux qui ont besoin de la
pitié du genre or c'est précisément de
cette pitié que nous ne voulons à tout
prix
je dirais même que de cette pique et
nous n'avons absolument pas besoin nous
demandons pas du tout le régime de
faveur nous demandons simplement que
l'on tienne compte de notre dignité
d'homme uniquement nous ne sommes pas
d'abord aveugle nous ne sommes nous
sommes d'abord hommes
les élèves du lycée la fontaine de paris
où comme professeur de français latin
une jeune femme aveugle une centaine de
non-voyants étudier actuellement dans
les facultés de paris le province ils
occuperont plus tard des postes de
cadres importants
la demoiselle tessin a choisi
l'enseignement
nous l'avons rejointe dans son
appartement où elle vit seule vous êtes
je crois mademoiselle aveugle de
naissance
oui vous n'avez jamais vu non est-ce que
vous souvenez du moment où vous êtes
aperçu de cette cécité
non non absolument pas parlez moi de
votre enfance est ce que votre enfance a
été très différente de l'enfance des
autres enfants n'ont pas tellement
enfin je crois que j'ai surtout beaucoup
de chance parce que j'ai un frère qui
est presque mon jumeau puisqu'on à
treize mois de différence alors je me
suis enfin il s'est toujours efforcée de
me faire participer à ces jeux et de me
faire participer au jeu avec les autres
enfants si vous voulez quand il y avait
des enfants à la maison j'ai jamais eu
l'impression d'être exclu du jeu même
quand on jouait à cache cache ou 4
coincer ces jeux de gosse j'ai toujours
une impression de je me suis jamais
rendu compte que j'étais différente des
autres mais je dois dire que mon frère
cette manche occuper beaucoup de moi il
prenait toujours par la main et vous
êtes vous avez fait des études
secondaires
mais je crois que toutes vos études vous
les avez fait pratiquement dans le monde
des voyants oui puisque je suis allé au
lycée où tout le temps sauf un en cours
de mes études secondaires
mais alors comment avez vous pu faire
ses études secondaires en les suivant
dans un lycée de voyant là aussi j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance j'ai été très aidé à
la maison d'abord parce que mon frère
ayant juste un an de plus que moi
pouvait m'aider parce qu'il sortait de
la place dans laquelle je rentrais et
puis j'étais aussi très aidée par les
parents que ce soit mon père qui pouvait
tout de même mais d en mathématiques par
exemple ou en physique chimie et ma mère
qui était là pratiquement toute la
journée qui donc quand j'avais besoin de
chercher un mot dans le dictionnaire
surtout en particulier dictionnaire la
table parce que ça on en a pas en
braille donc il fallait il faut tout le
temps avoir quelqu'un à côté de soi là
j'avais toujours ma mère disponible pour
m'aider ou pour me lire quand je ne
disposais pas de livres en braille pour
m'aider
ils sont déjà j'étais très très aidée à
la maison est-ce que vous pensez que
cette aide beaucoup de parents peuvent
l'apporter aux jeunes aveugles
je crois qu ici prennent l'habitude de
considérer que le fait de voir un enfant
aveugle n'est pas quelque chose
d'extraordinaire et que l'enfant aveugle
n'est pas un encombrement dire que
souvent les parents recherchent une
solution de facilité
ils sont un petit peu dépassé par les
évènements cotisons agos aveugle et il
pense pour le mieux et sans décharger
auprès d'autres personnes
alors selon moi là là où l'enfant est
plus heureux c'est à la maison s'il
rencontre des parents compréhensifs
je crois même que j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance parce que que ce soit au lycée
que ce soit la sorbonne j'ai eu soit les
amis soit la famille surtout en sorbonne
alors les amis les amis c'est important
dans la vie d'une jalabert moi je dis
toujours que si je n'avais pas eu des
amis ma famille je ne serai jamais
arriver où j'en suis je dépends enfin
vraiment en ce qui concerne mes études
j'ai beaucoup dépendu des autres rioux
oui j'aime pas tellement cette
définition en latin surtout vous prenez
vous prendre tu comprends hâtivement
exactement le neutre singulier la plus
active ce qui va nous donner
dr
[Applaudissements]
quand je me trouve devant quarante
élèves j'ai hâte de les connaître aussi
rapidement que possible individuellement
et là pour le faire il faut absolument
qu'elle respecte la place choisie au
départ grâce ça j'arrive à les connaître
a ajouté que tout de même en enseignants
parents de cette classe vous avez vu je
les onze heures par semaine alors le
fait d'avoir des enfants 11 heures
permet de les connaître très vite il pas
ce qui me frappe par exemple au lycée
c'est de voir avec quelle naturel les
élèves viennent m'adresser la parole que
ce soit d'ailleurs les petits tous les
grandes et les petites très vite alors
qu'au début
e par exemple j'ai une assistante pour
m'aider je me rappelle très bien que les
quatre ou cinq premiers jours les
petites quand elles ont une question à
poser est d'ordre pratique n'est ce pas
la grosseur du cahier ou bien eu le
livre à porter et bien ne venez pas me
demander à moi est allé demander à mon
assistante ce que je ne voulais
absolument pas et bien très vite elles
prennent l'habitude de venir s'adresser
directement à moi alors que j'ai des
adultes enfin je connais des adultes qui
encore actuellement au lycée ne
m'adresse pas la parole même adresse par
personne interposée et en dehors de
votre travail mademoiselle quels sont
vos loisirs
oh il y aille à la lecture bien sûr vous
lisez quoi je vous lis bien ça dépend je
viens peut toujours l'idée roman puis je
lis des revues bien sûr mais des romans
et les revues en braille e bay roman non
je préfère lire pendant de magnétique
sur un magnétophone
c'est moins encombrant à transporter
d'abord sur les volumes bryce est énorme
il existe même des revues des revues
magnétique au fait je pense par exemple
au monde
eh bien je reçois le monde sur bande
magnétique en hiver une couche là sous
l'édredon et puis je lui lis le
magnétophone sans avoir à faire un geste
là je suis bien au chaud moi je trouve
que c'est un mode de lecture
r depuis j'ai le magnétophone julie
presque plus en braille surtout ça me
demande un effort que le magnétophone et
vite et en dehors de cette lecture vous
faites du sport
eux oui en été en était là
attention déchu méridionale alors pour
nager il faut vraiment que les eaux soit
chaude que le temps soit chaud qui fait
que j'ai peu de goût pour la natation en
hiver et puis si nous faisons beaucoup
de tandem je dois dire avec mon frère où
est ma belle-soeur enfin ça nous avons
acheté un tandem et sont passionnés par
le tandem avez vous mademoiselle songez
à vous marier
non jamais j'ai toujours pensé que
c'était impossible
essentiellement à cause de la question
des enfants il y aurait une chance sur
cent pour mon enfant ne vois pas je m'en
sentirai responsable tout le temps et je
n'arriverai jamais je crois que j'aurai
toujours l'impression que que j'aurais
rendu mon gosse malheureux enfin
incontestablement à cause de l'hérédité
je ne le sont je ne pourrais pas
envisagé est ce que dans votre vie
mademoiselle de jeunes aveugles vous
avez de grands moments de découragement
oui oh la la
moi ça oui mais enfin je crois que tout
le monde en a de grands moments
j'exagère il ya des moments de fatigue
ou je trouve que vraiment mon sort et le
plus misérable de la terre enfin ça
correspond toujours ou des moments de
fatigue ou à des mouvements de surcroît
de travail mais ça je m'en inquiète pas
parce que ma nature n'est pas de nous
complaire dans dans le pessimisme alors
il y en a mais je pense que tout le
monde en a de toutes façons
est ce que vous estimez avoir réussi
votre intégration au monde des voyants
je crois que l'intégration totale et
absolument impossible alors je dis que
je les réussis au maximum en ce sens que
je peux travailler comme si je voyais je
peux mener une vie qui est presque comme
si je voyais mes l'intégration totale en
ce qui me concerne ce sera toujours
impossible
je vous estimez quand même différente
des autres jeunes femmes
oui automatiquement enfin il ya tout de
même toute une partie de ma vie que je
n'aurais jamais réalisée et que je ne
réalisera jamais les risques d'hérédité
en ce qui concerne la société non
accidentels sont dans certains cas
difficiles a précisé
bien souvent ces hommes ces femmes se
retrouve seul devant la responsabilité
50 à 55% des femmes aveugles se marie ce
chiffre est nettement moins élevé pour
les femmes
bien que recherchant de préférence leur
conjoint dans le monde des voyants il
arrive aussi que les aveugles se marient
entre eux madame louise on a rencontré
son époux
au centre spécialisé de belleville où
tous deux apprenez la dactylographie oui
alors cinq minutes où la première phase
environ et trois minutes de l'autre
je vois que vous êtes très habile ici
madame dans cet appartement vous avez
mis longtemps des habitués on
ça fait six mois que nous sommes ici ça
va ça va et comment fait vos points de
vue ménages par exemple l ena je cite
ainsi difficile mais il faut faire avec
méthode progressivement l'un côté puis
l'autre puis comment faites vous pour
vos vêtements vous êtes jeune femme très
soignée à main je demande si j'ai
l'impression d'avoir fait une tâche et
je préfère demander que me promenais
avec mandela qu'ils soient nés amis qui
viennent ici ou bien au bureau même si
vous je crois qui fait les courses
oui j'arrive avant madame alors souvent
je fais les courses
en attendant mais comment faites vous
parler chez les commerçants pour dd pour
l'argent si vous voulez et bien pour
l'argent c'est il ya une petite méthode
à suivre on y croit je place d'avoir mes
billets par an dans les cinq sens avec
les enfants des fois même les prix des
différentes manières de manière on
attrape sur les mentions du billet que
je donne
un tel ou tel commerçant vous allez
toujours chez les mêmes commerçants
peut-être souvent oui et pour la mener
ce sont les commerçants qui vous aident
à principe dit nous disent combien il
disait ça fait ça fait tomber je vérifie
toujours regarder vous avez confiance en
général dans les gens qui vous entourent
disons que une confiance quand même
limité quoi quelques fois vous devrez
déjà qu'ils sont trop gentils
apparemment et qui finalement membres
profitent de la situation aujourd'hui
alors on a quand même une tendance à se
méfier mais plus ou moins quoi tout
dépend des relations avec le personnel
vous avez un petit bébé
il ya trois mois comment s'appelle-t-il
parce que pascal et lui voit il vous est
certaine les examens dès la maternité et
on le fera suivre tous les six mois mais
pour l'instant le docteur et avant de
vous marier ce que vous avez pensé que
vous auriez pu avoir un enfant est
atteint de cécité
avez-vous pensé je ne souhaitais pas
irriter un a de grandes chances qu'il
n'y soit pas c'est cela
c'est jamais on ne sait jamais vous
dites n'est pas trop sûr quand même vous
occuper beaucoup de petits abris
justement je crois que vous avez des
problèmes avec ce petit quand il est
venu au monde ont fait la maternité on a
voulu vous l'enlever oui bien sûr parce
que les personnes ne sont pas tellement
averti et ne pense pas que qu'on puisse
s'en occuper et vous arrivez réellement
vous en occuper maintenant tout va très
bien oui vous l'avez tous les jours avec
vous ah non malheureusement parce que je
travaille à louis jeune geek au big n
mais je fais tout les subit france ne
l'avait sa toile est oui mais vous avez
pensé plus tard au moment où il va
grandir quand vous devrez les le
conduire à l'école aller le chercher
pour lui si on y est vous avez pensé aux
problèmes de l'obéissance plus tard vos
enfants vont grandir pour penser pouvoir
vous faire obéir aussi bien que quimper
le voyant je l'espère donnera à oui on
va de ce côté-là il oubliera je lui
expliquerai enfin jeunes de ce côté-là
ça habitués à mentir c'est ça vaut vous
comptez lui expliquer très tôt votre
cécité oui il y sera tout de suite dans
le bain si je puis dire alors pour lui
je pense pas que ça pose un problème
[Musique]
bon